alors francis m'attendais un pour
déjeuner il attendait une a dit tiens
c'est bizarre
une heure et demie est toujours pas
rentré j'entendais mon téléphone qui
sonnait c'était francis qui m'a appelé
pour me dire alors qu'est-ce que youtube
et moi je pouvais pas ils étaient là et
alors et prenez il avait un chargeur un
sac à dos et sortait plein de balles et
puis claque a claqué mettait dans le
chargeur il reposait le chargeur et puis
il était là disait de toute façon j'ai
des revendications vous avez dévoilé nos
femmes vous avez attaqué les pays
musulmans il ya la palestine donc j'ai
des revendications allez vous allez
prendre un de vos portables appelé la
police et je vais leur dire vous devez
d'abord vous que je vous garde en otage
la et puis alors donc on a appelé la
police répondait pas c'est bizarre une
police qui répond pas c'est pas possible
et on avait très peur et puis après d'un
seul coup il a dit il ya des gens encore
au sous-sol là il faut les faire monter
parce que si moi j'ai de moi je devais
aller les chercher chez les hommes tout
de suite comme ça et donc dans les
personnes dont quand il ya quelqu'un qui
est parti une vendeuse une caissière est
parti chercher les personnes qui
s'étaient cachés au sous sol
quand ils sont montés moi j'étais un peu
à l'arrière donc j'ai pas tout vu toutes
les personnes mais je savais qu'elle
était là il a demandé à un client qui
était là quelques ailes et quel est ton
quel est ton nom à l'oreille a dit mme
chapel le philippe peut-être un autre
prénom arabe il est alors tu t'appelles
fini mais comment alors il a dit par
exemple comme salomon il a tiré tout de
suite j'ai vu l'homme ses jambes ça fait
c'est tout le monde avait la barre ici
ne pouvait plus bouger ne pouvait plus
déglutir ne pouvait plus rien faire